hello everyone and welcome to round six
of the 2019 Tata Steel chess tournament
like we said there was a rest day and
everyone's always anxious how the games
are going to turn out after the rest day
will be a series of adult draws or will
there be fireworks on the board and
there are still some games being played
while I'm recording this but there have
been quite a few decisive games let's
just put it like that and I will show
definitely a few more games from this
round so we're gonna save this standings
for for a few of those games so here we
have Magnus Carlsen world chess champion
versus chakra and mamedyarov
and who needs no introduction but I
think he is currently third on the
world's rating lists right behind for me
on a Caruana but he has dropped on the
live rating list I think Dingley and now
overtook his place as the number three
in the world but only a lot live ratings
we'll have to wait until February and of
course until the end of this tournament
to see how it goes but yeah okay without
further ado Coulson managed to break the
curse and win his previous games so
let's see how he faces off against the
mummy DRO Knight to f3 d5 we have d4
Knight to f6 c4 and the D captures on c4
the software the Queen's pawn opening
but after e3 we transpose into the
Queens gambit accepted so okay we have
east six this is a very theoretical
opening so a lot of the moves that are
being played here are all standard
theory that has been used many times
before the ship captures on c4
developing a piece with tempo grabbing a
pawn c5 attacking the center if you want
you always want to play c5 especially
when there's something to attack with it
we have castles a6 and the now b3 but
white is not worried about b5 as this
will be overextending on the Queen side
a bit not really not really gaining all
that much as b3 has been played so c4
will never be an idea for black B sex
preparing to fianchetto the lights were
bishop and now D captures on c5 caution
as usual
is you know down with exchanging Queens
Queen captures mom in Europe goes for
this rook captures and Bishop captures
on c5 again developing the bishop while
capturing upon Bishop to b2 Carson
develops the fiend cat was the dark
square Bishop and this Knight B to d7
Knight B to d2
we have Bishop to d7 all standard
developing moves you know just trying to
develop your pieces as naturally as
possible bash up the back to e2 making a
room for the night on c4 and the now
castles by Mahmoud er of Knights to c4
and rook F to D 800k Oh cousin still
wants to play rock a c1 1 meter want to
play rock a c8 and here Knights the e1
he wants to bring this night over to d3
to attack the Bishop on c5 and here this
position is known in the database b5
there is one game that b5 has been used
but here after Bishop to b5 the move
mama door mama are abused we have a
completely new game on our hands
okay rook 8 2 c1 cousin brings the the
last undeveloped piece into the game
locate the see a comedy or does the same
and not nice the d3 attacks the Bishop
on c5 of course mom Dara wants to keep
his Bishop air so he retreats with the
Bishop Bishop to e7 and now Knight ct5 a
very active square for the knight also
offers a trader Robson see under C file
about a trade of rooks isn't I really
either of them is looking for everyone
wants the other player to grab first but
of course neither will do it but should
be back to b7 and now comes Knight back
to c4 we have a bushel back to d5 would
this move perhaps mamedyarov is just
testing cross and will he be interested
in a draw by repeating moves but hardly
with the white pieces so Carson goes
back with the nights and nights the d2
and forces Mahmud off the play on the
show back to b7 Amemiya repeats and now
came to f1 improving the position of the
King Bishop to f3 is an idea and the
king will also be able to join in join
in all the fun h6 and bush
to f3 now offering a trade of a light
square bishop some but tonight the d5
Mammadov
declines it we have night back to see
for pressuring the b6 pawn and now b5
kicking the knight back Knights to a 5
attacking the bishop on b7 and now
Bishop to a e8 and now a 3 and ok cross
indeed make some progress here he did
push this Bishop all the way to a 8 and
and there is at least something going on
but on the other hand with his pawn on
b3 and blacks control of the C 4 squared
that night is pretty stranded on a 5 and
ok g5 mama your F says okay now we are
definitely playing this game and he
stops repeating moves decides to play on
the kingside h3 f5 now grabbing a lot of
space here on the kingside and b4 by
Carlsen preparing night b3 retreating
with the night you do have to activate
it you don't want your Knights to be
stranded on the edge of the board as you
all know the night under on the rim is
grim or some say dim but yeah preparing
Knight b3 and creating a very nice
outpost for the knight on c5 as from b3
both of the Knights will be controlling
c5 King to f7 and now comes Knight to b3
as planned
Bishop to f6 offering a trade of dark
square bishop sand cross and accepts it
Bishop captures and now you have to
capture with the King you can't capture
with the bishop as then you will for
example in special captures Bishop
captures 0 captures and now this rook
can infiltrate via the C file so we
don't want to allow white in any such
small advantages so King captures on f6
and now Knight beat the c5 finally
grabbing this outpost and also
pressuring the a6 pawn because you
cannot defend with Bishop to b7 as the
knight is controlling the b7 square on
the other hand you don't want to capture
the night if you capture then Knight
captures again this pawn is under attack
and now you can't defend it with the
rook because you're getting in the line
of this bishop and if you play something
like night here then white can easily
win the game with Knight d7 check it's
too overwhelming King g6 now rook
captures on c7 rock characters and now
95 check will pick up the rook
here will now be completely winning rook
captures if you capture tonight then you
lose the bishop and if first Bush
captures then the knight can recapture
and still you are up a full piece
so after Knight bc5 you have night five
to be six my job
creates a little trick because here if
Carson goes for the pawn with Knight
characters on a sex then after Bishop
captures on f3 pawn captures and night
c4 he will have a very nice control of
the C file the the a3 point is a bit
weak and even though he's down upon for
the moment cousins pawn structure is a
bit messed up he definitely has
compensation so here after night 5 b6
Carlsen first retreats with the Bishop
Bishop to e2 avoids this exchange and
messing up of his own pawn structure and
gains further control of the C 4 square
to prepare for the arrival of this night
we have nice to see four and now comes a
for now the a tree pawn is no longer a
target and also by cannot capture
because the pond has to keep an eye on
the denied on c4 so we have Knight d2 b6
preparing now to capture as the knight
is now controlling the guarding denied
on c4 but now a5 forcing the knight back
we have nice to d5 and now the a6 pawn
is finally weak and cross and grabs it
Knight captures on a6 but mama dear I've
had everything planned out he decides to
go for this very nice well it's not a
sacrifice it's a - two pieces for a rook
and the pawn but you know Knight
captures on e3f captures Knight captures
with check King has to move King t1 and
now Knight captures on d1 so grabbing
the rook rook captures on d1 Carson
doesn't want to allow further trades and
now rook to c2 so as you can see mama
Dara is now up upon its five to four and
Crossan has two knights for form a madea
of the rook for the moment white will
always be better because two pieces are
better than a rook and regardless of
course on being a pawn down he does have
a past a pawn which of course is very
strong as it's a protected passed pawn
it's okay Bishop to f3 you want a course
and wants to exchange a light square
bishop
Bishop to e4 going after the night here
now you cannot capture the bishop s
after pawn captures the knight will be
hanging and the broken d1 is undefended
so night 8 night comes the c5 trying to
include the other night into the game
and now you can see that already this
spawn is very dangerous
this past pawn is well we could say a
very fast bushel capture son d3 look
captures on d3 rook captures on d3 and
now Knight factors on d3 we have E 5
preparing efore to win a piece here you
have to move the knight or the bishop
first you want to move the bishop cousin
plays Bishop to b7 as you want to keep
control of the a it's where you don't
want to allow this Bishop to stay here
and then if he for is played then the
bishop is no longer controlling a 8
which is the queening square so first
bishop to b7 now comes p4 and night to
c5 so already you can see that if this
pawn was on a7 it would be winning
cousin will just have the Queen and the
Queen in square is protected so King to
e5 by Mahmoud er of now comes a 6 and
rook - a - you cannot allow white to
push a 7 and now there are a couple of
ways you can approach this position you
can either try Knight b3 in the block of
the rook with 95 or the idea that Carson
goes for which is better up to c6 you
wanna win the b5 one as well and then
just push the beep on to victory and
here is the critical moment of the game
where my media of he you know he decided
that this position was a draw and in
that regard he is correct but it's not a
draw regardless of what you play here
mommy are played h5 which is the losing
there was the only way to go to go for
not losing this game is either king d4
or e3 one such line is III bringing your
pawn even closer to queening and now
after Bishop captures on b5 King d4 and
here it's very hard for white to make a
move for example if Bishop to d3
it's f4 is coming you you don't want to
lose this point but now white can tree
move anything you can't move this pawn
as it's not protected you can't move the
b5 pawn because the B be pawn protects
the night and c5 you can't move the
knight because it protects the blush
upon d3 so white a black would be able
to hold in this position but here it's
after h5 the move mom you're up late
it's simply too late for for black cross
and grabs the pawn and now the same idea
no longer applies if you try a three now
your one move too late now comes the
Bishop City for a cousin would attack
the rook after Luke a1 check King would
move and now it doesn't matter if for
example King D for you simply lose
tonight b3 check because you lose the
rook and if you try to bring your rook
to a3 let's say and then it's really
just then it's just beautiful how white
wins night b3 you're preparing Knight a5
to block off the rook now comes eetu you
force whites the capture so white has to
give up tonight Bishop captures rook
captures here and now b5 the bishop is
controlling the b5 pawn king to d6 you
want to use your king to stop the pawns
but now comes a 7 Roque 3 you prevent
the point from queening and now comes b6
and here's the real problem now you
cannot approach the pawns with the king
you cannot go here because the point is
controlling c7 and you cannot go here
because if you go here then you see how
white wins a8 Queen rook has the capture
and then Bishop to have to recheck picks
up the rook in captures Bishop captures
and now with two pawns and a bishop this
is a winning endgame for white so after
Bishop captures on b5 mama yarrow here
saw that he messed up and he had to
devise a different plan he played the g4
and okay H capture so we have H captures
and now comes Bishop to c4 my Magnus
attacking the rook preparing there's the
idea of the little trick that we
mentioned if you okay one check which is
played King h2 now of course the King
cannot approach because the bishop and
Knight be three winning in the rook with
a fork so f4 here we have b5 by crossing
and now comes F 3 B 6 by Crossin and
here King to f4 and here Carlson has a
lot of ways to continue this game the
problem is if you play something like b7
then you this is met with g3 check King
h3 and rook H 1 will be checkmate so
this is one way for Carlson to blunder
the game but of course he did not become
world champion for blundering games in
such a fashion it did happen a few times
in his career of course but not in this
particular game here cross simply Knight
captures on e4 simply forcing the King
to move away from the pond the night now
controls g3 so g3 check is impossible
and it was in this position that shah
karim ahmadiyya resigned the game why
did he resign well if you just ignore
the night and try to you know get your
pawn active it doesn't really work the
Knights still controls f2 you don't gain
anything by capturing here b7 b8 is
coming it's completely winning for white
on the other hand if you capture the
night then there's no real danger of g3
and white was simply pushed b7 and next
move will win the game if you if you
play rook b1 then a 7 is coming still
winning there is one way
cousin could blunder this for example if
King III now b8 Queen and now king f2 if
for some reason cross and didn't start
with checks and decided that he wants
another Queen for some sort of weird
reason then black has a winning idea so
feel free to pause the video it's
actually a nice idea you know it could
happen in your own games if your
opponent is careless or greedy or or
whatnot or or he likes Queens I don't
know but yeah feel free to pause the
video here and try to find it it's
checkmate for black I'll give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are a very tricky player and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
rook to h1 forcing the king to capture
after the king characters now f captures
and G 2 comes with check King has to
move and now point to g1 Queen is
checkmate because of course the point is
guarding the h3 square so there are were
ways for Carlsen to blunder but mama drf
doesn't doesn't test him he simply after
this night captors on e4 he decided to
resign the game
yeah a very nice victory for Coulson
after those 20 draws enroll now two wins
in a row so we could you know perhaps
we'll see now a huge winning streak but
yeah like we said I will show some other
games from around six of the 2019 Tata
Steel chess tournament and then we're
gonna talk a bit more about the
standings but as some games are still
being played I think it will be a
four-four player draw across an apology
and onigiri are currently tied for first
and I believed England will join them as
his game will most likely end in a draw
but we'll definitely talk about that
some more I would like to thank Anthony
Savoy Ric Seeger Douglas Perry John
Merlino and Tyler garage for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon don't worry we're definitely
continuing the couple Blancas saga but
you know that saga is not going anywhere
this is happening right now so we do
have to cover the current events as well
so thank you all and I will see you soon